last week after the forthcoming roe v
wade decision from the supreme court
leaked there was immediately speculation
about who did the leaking now much of
the speculation was really in bad faith
it was right-wingers arguing that the
real problem here is that there was a
leak rather than the fact that women's
rights are going to be potentially set
back by decades thanks to a number of
activist judges placed on the supreme
court by failed former president donald
trump so the issue isn't actually the
leaker but the right wanted to make the
leak or the issue and the right
immediately said obviously this is a
left-wing leaker
who wants to pressure
justices to change their votes
to keep roe v wade by making them fear
for their lives and
you know followed from there and as i
said last week we don't know the
political orientation of the leaker
there are two at least equally plausible
explanations one is the leaker is on the
left the leaker is pro-choice and the
idea of the leaker was i'm going to leak
this now
so that the justices planning to vote to
overturn roe v wade will be pressured
and they will be harassed and they might
fear for their lives and they'll say
okay okay i'll keep roe v wade
now
these are appointments for life supreme
court justices of great security
it's not super likely that that is
actually the case but it is a
possibility
just as likely is the opposite and again
we didn't know one way or the other but
just as likely is the hypothesis that
the leaker is right wing why would a
right winger leak the decision a right
winger would leak the decision
to
make sure
that by making the expected votes public
none of the justices that are at least
as of the february draft planning to
vote to overturn roe v wade changed
their minds
imagine that i don't know
kavanaugh was on the overturn row side
back in february when the draft was
written but since is thinking you know
maybe i should maybe i should vote to
keep it the idea would be a right winger
leaks it to put pressure on those
justices not to change their votes
either one is possible but now we are
actually getting more and more
information that the right-wing leaker
scenario is the more probable one uh
nina totenberg who is a longtime supreme
court reporter says actually
the main theory now is that this was a
right-wing clerk who leaked this take a
listen been covering the court since the
early days of roe how much has this leak
rattled the institution and and the way
it's viewed
well the way it's viewed it's it's an
earthquake and i think within the court
itself it's an earthquake there has
never been a leak like this there have
been minor little springs that have
emerged from the court uh
reports of a
a tentative vote or misbehavior by one
justice back in the 50s 60s 70s
there were leaks those kinds of leaks
but never an entire draft of a majority
opinion that has never ever
occurred before and it can only
in all likelihood have come from a
justice that i think is less likely
perhaps one of the clerks and the
leading
the leading theory is a conservative
clerk who was afraid that one of the
conservatives might be persuaded by
chief justice roberts into to join a
much more
moderate opinion um and then there's
another theory that it was an outraged
liberal clerk but i think the only one
that makes
sense is that it came from somebody
who was afraid that this majority might
not hold that chief justice roberts
might persuade one of the conservatives
to come over to him so this type of
reporting is increasingly pointing to a
right winger now we may never know but
remember ted cruz and others were saying
jail the leaker they were assuming it
was a liberal and they were saying you
got to jail them ted cruz actually went
on fox news and said the leaker should
be jailed remember this reason it was
leaked
is some left-wing presumably law clerk
wanted to put political pressure on the
five justices that presumably are in the
majority right now they wanted to put
heat and they wanted to invoke politics
to try to get them to change their vote
and and by the way if that left-wing law
clerk succeeds it will be the most
grotesque politicization of the supreme
court in the history of our nation you
mentioned an fbi investigation i hope
there is a serious one and i hope
whoever is responsible for this not only
is fired instantly but is prosecuted and
serves real jail time for violating the
confidences of the supreme court and
then the last real liberal by which i
mean a right-wing reactionary tool c
gabbard she went on tv and also said we
we've got to prosecute in inject but
what's the crime tool see she didn't say
to be heard i think it's also critical
to point out that
this leak sets a very very dangerous
precedent for our supreme court for
three important reasons number one is
first of all this person is a thief who
stole this information released it with
a very specific intent to try to incite
protesters and intimidate and pressure
our supreme court justices to make a
political decision rather than a
decision that is based on the
constitution uh number two we have the
fact that um you know the supreme court
is not in place to legislate from the
bench uh people's representatives at the
state level at the federal level are
charged to make laws not the supreme
court the supreme court needs to make
decisions based on the constitution and
the department of justice lastly needs
to go and prosecute this
crime which is exactly what it is and
make an example out of the person who
leaked this information because our
supreme court justices cannot operate
under the fear that they will have
partisan political activists in their
house
intimidating and threatening their
ability to do their job per the
constitution and there was a
do they still want them jailed if it is
a right winger but more importantly will
we ever actually find out who did it i
don't know that we will
one of our sponsors is cheese butter
giving you 20
cheese butter is a delicious gourmet
cheese melt that ingeniously blends for
indulgent cheeses and artisanal seasoned
butter i love this stuff cheese bud is
the type of thing you've got to try to
really understand
there's so many different things i was
already putting cheese and butter on but
by combining top shelf cheeses and
butters together cheese butter unlocks a
new level of tasty gourmet goodness and
there are actually several cuisines with
sauces that mix these ingredients it may
be new to you but it is a
tried and true combination very often
cheese butter will make an appearance
when i'm cooking at home i put it on
french and sourdough bread bagels
english muffins it's great on sandwiches
grilled cheese burgers baked potatoes
mac and cheese broccoli broccolini my
beloved broccolini other vegetables i'm
sure there's lots of other home chefs in
the audience who can come up with some
great ways to use cheese butter and
you'll now get 20 off when you go to
cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below